well
hello how are you greetings sali jaramillo
with his brief informative for today more than
5 october a shooting involving
a police officer ended with one
man dead and one officer injured this
happened last night around 6:40
inside a complex  apartment near
penguin and order police said they
responded to a domestic violence report
when they arrived at the scene
shots were fired the suspect was
killed while an officer was
injured another woman on the scene was also
injured this is all the
information so far  will reveal
the identity of those involved in the
coming days
today snider is the night that
law enforcement agencies
share with the las vegas community
the objective of this event is to help
create a safer environment and
improve coexistence among residents
there will be fun for the whole family
this event will be in downtown cement
on park center drive near the
restaurant c  razy pira is completely
free and starts at five
o'clock the world gaming expo kicked off this morning at the
sean expos convention center where the latest
in casino technology betting
virtual sports and much more will be highlighted the expo
returns to town after  a year of
absence due to the
coronavirus pandemic, however, several of the
technologies that were revealed in 2019
are already in some of the
casinos in the script and now we turn to
the weather forecast we will have a
temperature with a maximum of 80 degrees
for today  we will continue with some
drizzle for the rest of the day
a cloudy sky is not expected for the rest of
the week with lows rolling in the 60s
beautiful day salí jaramillo greets you and
this was your brief informative edition
in Spanish
[Music]